in the last hour the amazon founder and
billionaire jeff bezos
has returned from his maiden space
voyage the new shepherd craft blasted
off with its crew
including bezos's brother and the
youngest
and oldest people to have ever been into
space
it's the first commercial flight for the
tycoon's blue origin space tourism
company
the capsule reached a height of around
100 kilometers above earth
just on the edge of space the passengers
experienced about three minutes of being
weightless
before beginning their descent
and touchdown the capsule landed safely
at t
plus 10 minutes and elated jeff bezos
and crewmo shortly after
on the texas launch sites he could be
heard describing the trip as
the best day ever
live now to rob reynolds who's near that
launch site for us in van horn
texas sir rob just walk us through the
events of the past 60 minutes
well uh peter it was a pretty uh
exciting
time for people watching all around the
world and
and for us here to be able to see the
contrail of the rockets shooting
straight up into the air
was really an amazing sight the
blast off came after a couple of delays
but when it did come it was uh without
incident
uh the uh rocket uh by jeff
uh that has been developed by jeff
bezos's blue origin
corporation with the uh shepherd ii
capsule on top reached an altitude of
about 100 kilometers above the earth
the uh speed of the
ascent was three times the speed of
sound mach
3 so they were really feeling the
g-forces i'm sure as they were
uh strapped in uh in that capsule then
the
booster rocket detached uh floated back
to earth where it uh
landed uh intact and after uh several
minutes
of uh weightlessness uh a lot of
shouting and gleeful uh uh
noise from the uh four passengers in the
uh
fully automated capsule it too began its
descent
and deployed its parachutes
landed softly and successfully
in the texas desert and then we are now
waiting
for a press conference by jeff bezos and
the other three uh newly minted
astronauts
uh which should take place in an hour or
two from now we we haven't been given an
exact time
for that event to take place but we will
uh certainly
hear more from uh these new space
travelers about what their experience
was like and
uh you know peter for for those of us
who are
old enough to remember the early days of
space exploration both the
the the russian or soviet uh
exploits and the american apollo program
that reached the moon
52 years ago today which is no
coincidence by the way of course
jeff bezos planned it that way these
images really did kind of i think
return that sense of excitement that
sense of crossing a new frontier
that sense of new possibilities
uh uh escaping from from earth's bonds
and going into space albeit for just
a few minutes um and and that really i
think
is something that uh perhaps is is the
most significant thing that that might
come away from this
um sure it was in part ego driven by the
world's richest man
it was in part uh an attempt to launch a
lucrative
space tourism enterprise but it's it's
the lasting impact
of this may be to get some people a
little more excited
about the idea of uh journeying beyond
earth
uh and seeing what possibilities there
might be for mankind
uh in doing so not simply
as a stunt but as perhaps some way of
finding lasting scientific
uh discoveries and contributions for the
people of earth
dear of mankind forgive me rob for my
next question i'm not going to ask you
anything about to do with a potential
space race between
wealthy entrepreneurs who are worth
billions and billions
you and i have spent the last 18 months
talking about covid and coronavirus and
massive death tolls and massive
infection rates
is there a link of commonality however
between the events today
and the space missions of the apollo era
when it was at its height
and it's hope it's about america being
allowed to feel good again
about america there's good times coming
back it kind of
inculcates that atmosphere of oh this
this has been a success we can enjoy
this
for some i think yes but we live in a
very different america
than than we did in 1969 when
uh when when human beings first
stepped on on the moon it's a divided
country
uh there are people who refuse to
believe
the coronavirus is a real thing there
are people who
know the coronavirus is a real thing and
yet refuse to
get uh readily available injections to
prevent it
there are those who refuse to wear masks
uh so the politicized atmosphere uh
that exists in 2021 is is far
different from even uh the uh the the
again highly politicized and conflicted
atmosphere
of the late 1960s but uh
having having said all that i think yes
there will be
certainly some people who will feel this
is an accomplishment this
shows what people with great engineering
skills with
enormous scientific knowledge uh with
with about belief in science which is
important uh what they can do and what
they can accomplish
and that does carry with it some um some
message for
the the current state of affairs here on
earth with regard to
our global pandemic here on earth for
sure rob many thanks rob reynolds
reporting live there
from van horn in texas
well earlier this month the entrepreneur
richard branson as we've been hearing
took off his
specially designed rocket plane they are
both major milestones in the push
towards private commercial space
travel like branson bezos and his new
shepard craft didn't go fast enough
to go around the planet so it's being
called a sub-orbital flight
instead passengers spent a few minutes
experiencing weightlessness
bezos did reach outer space which the
world governing body the fia
puts at around 100 kilometers above the
surface
now branson only made it to what some
say is the edge of space his virgin
galactic mission
reaching an altitude of 88 kilometers
both commercial flights are still
a good way from the international space
station which orbits
uh earth at around 400 kilometers above
us
spacex the company owned by the third
billionaire elon musk
has already delivered astronauts to the
space station his commercial flights
are due to launch later this year let's
talk now to tanya harrison she's a
fellow
at the university of british columbia's
outer space institute she joins us
on skype from washington dc tania
harrison welcome to al jazeera
is today a game changer
i would say so we're finally seeing all
of these commercial space companies
getting to the point where they're
launching
humans to either the edge of space or
into space
and that's really going to change the
paradigm of you know how much it costs
and how difficult it is to send humans
not just for space tourism but for
scientific research
and sending more humans to the space
station what do we
get from it
in terms of humanity in general i mean
rob put it really well
in his field report actually there's not
just inspiration
coming to people watching this in the
hopes that they might want to enter
something related to space
they might want to enter science and
technology and engineering fields that
benefit us here on earth you know
working on satellites that image the
earth every day to
teach us about the effects of climate
change or work on engineering to help us
combat some of the impacts of climate
change
on the space station for example they're
doing a lot of biomedical research to
try and see if we can find
cures for infectious diseases or
treatments for cancer
and so there's a lot of impacts on
research that we do in space
that maybe the general public isn't all
that aware of but
everything that we do in space is really
geared at trying to improve our lives
here on earth
clearly for us uh tethered if you will
down here on terra firma we have got a
lot
from the space race from the apollo
mission the shuttle missions the russian
missions as well there's there's clearly
a trickle down and the technology the
technology that we're using to have this
conversation right now
this signal is going up up across and
down and you're talking to me and i'm
listening to you
and that's wonderful but given that
these people these three main people
jeff bezos richard branson and elon musk
are at the cutting edge of amazing
compelling astonishingly good technology
why doesn't somebody whisper in three
ears
and say you guys for the greater good of
humanity you guys should be working
together
that's an excellent question and i i
think even beyond that
why are governments not working more
closely you know space agencies with
these people
we're seeing this huge uh burst of
innovation
and the speed at which they can do
things that is so much faster than any
government can do
and so i think we could see
collaboration on that front to push more
scientific exploration more exploration
of space in general
and i mean at the end of the day it
would be really great to have this
star trek-esque world where we have
everybody working together for the
benefit of humanity
and not having these capitalistic fights
over
you know who can do the next thing first
who can make the most money
um unfortunately it's not the society
that we live in right now but maybe
someday we can get to that point i
certainly hope so
i think you've just changed into being
jean-luc picard uh tanya thank you so
much for talking to us we do appreciate
your time great to talk to you tanya
harrison there
talking to us on skype from dc